over the weekend Blizzard dazzled a lot
of gamers with cool announcements like
overwatch to Diablo 4 and hearthstone
auto chess I guess but what they failed
to do was distract me and a lot of
people from the whole mess they started
regarding Hong Kong sure they apologize
but they really alright let's start with
a quick recap Blizzard punished a par
stone player named blitz Chun for
voicing supports for the Hong Kong
protests on an official Blizzard stream
he was banned for a year along with two
casters though their punishments were
later dropped to six months just
reminders the people protesting in Hong
Kong are opposed to the mainland Chinese
government taking more control over the
Hong Kong government that control could
eventually lead to things like further
censorship or imprisonment for people
who criticize the mainland Chinese
government blizzards previous apology
kind of sucked and for more about that
you can watch our video
so with Blizzcon on the horizon a lot of
people were expecting Blizzard to at
least say something about the issue
meanwhile a lot of people were also
ready to protest at blizzards biggest
event of the year
obviously Blizzard wanted to get ahead
of the story a little bit so during his
official introductory Blizzcon keynote
Blizzard president Jay Alan brac
attempted to apologize you know Blizzard
had the opportunity to bring the world
together in a tough harsh tone eSports
moment about a month ago and we did not
we moved too quickly in our decision
making and then to make matters worse we
were too slow to talk with all of you
when I think about what I'm most unhappy
about there's really two things the
first one is we didn't live up to the
high standards that we really set for
ourselves and the second is we failed in
our purpose and for that I am sorry and
I accept accountability but he didn't
actually talk about the ban he didn't
say Blitz Chung's name he didn't really
talk about Hong Kong he didn't talk
about lifting the man he really didn't
say anything about the situation at all
see actions speak louder than words and
this is an apology well it's not an
apology for the ban it's an apology for
making people feel upset and unless they
are actually doing something like
lifting the ban Buzzard is effectively
saying that it feels bad but they don't
think they did anything wrong here we're
sorry we're sorry sorry and look you
don't have to take my word for it people
on Twitter are pretty upset too taking a
stand on this is important but as we've
noted before Blizzard has a lot of
Chinese business interests and while
they say those had nothing to do with
the decision to ban Blitz Chung it's
hard to imagine that the decision didn't
come from at least an attempt to appease
a Chinese market or otherwise make their
business partners happy
it was also potentially an opportunity
to send a message to make an example of
blitz Chung to anyone who was trying to
do something similar in the future now
it's important to note that brac says
that Blizzard is committed to doing
better in the days and months to come
which great but what are you doing right
now there's no reason a blizzard
couldn't have lifted blitz Chung's man
he didn't break any laws there's no
reason they couldn't have taken action
they just chose not to here look Brax
half-hearted apology was meant with
thunderous applause this was clearly an
incredible PR opportunity for Blizzard
imagine how much incredible PR would
have been generated if they just lifted
the ban so we're left with this half an
apology all words no actions so I want
to take a chance to highlight some of
the things that may have passed under
the radar over the last couple weeks in
this situation and you know try to shine
a light on those instead of blizzards
weaker apology first tempo storm picked
up blitz Chung and he'll be playing on
their hearthstone roster as soon as his
ban is up
honestly good on tempeh they're taking a
stand on the issue and sure it could be
seen as a calculated PR move but at the
end of the day they're supporting blitz
chump who isn't being supported by
Blizzard also the protest at Blizzcon
went on pretty much on a beta I
understand why a company would want to
stay away from political speech but when
it comes to something that is so
universal can transcend politics I feel
that they should support players
speaking up and on top of that people
protested in more creative ways yeah
free Hong Kong revolution of our times
sounds good to me hey there my name is
Lawrence iam so anyway the the identity
of the mysterious jailer being unknown
and somewhat a new figure and Warcraft
law is there a possibility that there
could be a character we know is
connected you go don't question me yeah
free Hong Kong all right thank you thank
you I also feel like it's really
important to quash the rumors that
Blizzard moved up announcements like
overwatch to and Diablo 4 up to distract
from the whole blitz chunk controversy
according to reporters in the know
that's just not true and even if it were
I really don't think it worked now a lot
of journalists got a chance to follow up
with brac after his comments at the
keynote and he said some really
interesting things to PC gamer first he
said that blitz Chun in the casters were
not getting their bands appealed and I'm
gonna read this quote directly so thanks
to Steven Messner and PC gamer
forgetting this interview we want the
official broadcasts which are a small
percentage of the overall content that
gets created to be about the games and
we want those to be focused on the games
again it's not about the content of
those chunks of message it's about the
fact that it was not around the games if
we hadn't taken action if we hadn't done
something you can imagine the trail that
would be in our future around doing
interviews they would become times for
people to make a statement about
whatever they wanted to on whatever
issue that's just a path we don't want
to go down we really want the content of
those official broadcast to be focused
on the games and keep that focus so a
blizzard saying that if you win say a
major hearthstone event and talk about
anything that isn't hearthstone
you're making a statement about
something inherently political that's
not
something they're interested in while
they say it's a dangerous precedent to
allow that I think it might be the
opposite there are plenty of award shows
and sporting events where people are
allowed to speak their minds and it's
only drawing people closer to those
personalities climate change is real it
is happening right now it is the most
urgent threat facing our entire species
but anyway BRAC had a more to say PC
Gamer followed that question up by
asking Brack if Woodson still would have
been banned if what he said wasn't
political and Breck basically says yes
the content was not the problem
it was the fact that it was not about
the game in question it was something
very specifically different I think and
I don't want to speculate around if he
had said this that or the other and how
would have gone I think that's a
difficult thing to think about but it's
not about the content of his message
there are many people that are
supportive of him and his message I want
to take a second and say that this is a
little bit wild to me what Brack is
saying is that bliss Chung's messages
were inherently political in this took
away and distracted from the game at
hand I get that and sure maybe Blizzard
doesn't like that but by banning blitz
cheong they've participated in the
politics of all of this they've made it
even more political and bigger than it
ever was before
they've taken a sign the politics are
unavoidable now and they've only made
things worse over the last couple of
weeks anyway
Brack went on to tell PC gamer that
Blizzard decision to ban blitz chunk was
actually partially influenced by China
he clarified that the post on blizzards
Weibo about how the ban was done to
protect China's national pride or
something like that wasn't made by
Blizzard but rather by Nettie's who
publishes all of wizards games in China
now Nettie's was apparently also part of
the conversation around banning blitz
Chung
along with blizzards Taiwan team and the
hearthstone leadership team all right
look I know we've talked about this
issue a million times here you've
watched three videos at this point about
it but I think it's really important to
keep Blizzard honest idol love closer to
handle the situation properly next time
and it seems like they want to but I
think myself and a lot of people would
like a real apology not a half-hearted
one that gets received by thunderous
applause this kind of thing will keep
happening as eSports in gaming get
bigger and bigger and scenes get more
global this situation will come up time
and time again
and I think that it's really important
that we as eSports fans and gamers hold
these massive companies accountable
anyway that's all I have to say about
this it has been three videos of this
you are probably sick and tired of
hearing me babble on about this [ __ ] so
it's the last time I really hope it's
the last time
Blizzard please don't [ __ ] up again I
feel like if anything the reason they
move the reason they announced overwatch
2 and Diablo 4 with no release date
possibly in sight was because the last
Blizzcon was a [ __ ] disaster right
you know I mean that's all it is right
it's the for overwatch too isn't even a
sequel it's an expansion pack we're
again G wears a hoodie now mercy got a
haircut
overwatch - it's just seriously it's
like last year Blizzcon was bad of
course they're gonna push up their
announcements because they need to look
good after last year they didn't know
about the Blitz should't thing they
haven't like three weeks to prepare for
that oh how would they possibly have
move that forward I'm taking a stand
this is the this is the hell I'm gonna
die on no mercy mercy out of better
haircut before they gave mercy the
haircut of a mom wants to speak to your
manager sucks